>> Tucker: LAST WEEK
SENATOR JOSH HAWLEY SPOKE TO THE
NATIONAL CONSERVATIVE PHONE
CONFERENCE IN WASHINGTON.
HE GAVE IT GREAT SPEECH.
IT'S SMART AND INTERESTING
CREDITS ON LAYING ON IT IF YOU
LIKE TO WATCH IT.
NATURALLY BECAUSE THE SPEECH WAS
EFFECTIVE, THE LEFT IS COMING
OUT OF THE WOODWORK TO ACCUSE
HIM OF CRIME THINK.
BUT NOW SAYING HE IS IN
ANTI-SEMITES.
ANTI-SEMITE?
WHY?
BECAUSE DURING HIS SPEECH, HE
ACCURATELY DESCRIBED AMERICA'S
ELITE AS BEING GLOBALIST
COSMOPOLITANS WITH NO REAL
ATTACHMENT TO BECAUSE OF
AMERICA.
THEY ARE.
NOPE EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT.
NO ONE THINKS HOLLY IS AN
ANTI-SEMITE.
IF THE DAY, THEY PROBABLY
WOULD'VE BEEN UPSET A FEW YEARS
AGO WHEN PRESIDENT OBAMA SAID
THIS.
>> IT SHOULD BE NOTED THAT THIS
NEW INTERNATIONAL ELITE, THE
PROFESSIONAL CLASS THAT SUPPORTS
THEM, DIFFERENCE IN RESPECTS
FROM THE RULING ARISTOCRACY.
A DEEPER PERCENTAGE CONSIDER
THEMSELVES LIBERAL POLITICS.
MODERN COSMOPOLITANS.
>> Tucker: IT WAS TRUE WHEN
OBAMA SAID IT.
IT WAS TRUE AND SENATOR HOLLY
SAYS IT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
SO, DID WE MISS DESCRIBED THAT?
YOU ARE BEING CALLED AN
ANTI-SEMITES FOR DESCRIBING MANY
OF OUR ELITES AS NOT ATTACHED TO
UNITED STATES.
>> I GUESS THAT'S RIGHT THERE
WHAT I'VE LEARNED IS THAT WHEN
IT COMES TO LIBERALS, THERE'S
ONLY ONE THING THAT THEY LOVE
MORE THAN BEING ELITIST AND THAT
IS ACCUSING EVERYBODY ELSE OF
BEING BIGOTS.
IN ORDER TO SHUTDOWN SPEECH, IN
ORDER TO DISS AND VALUE OF THE
BEAUTY OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY SAY THE YOU ARE A BIGOTED,
RACIST, BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT
TO ADMIT WHAT THEY'VE DONE.
I DON'T WANT A NEW ADMIT WHAT
THEIR POLICIES HAVE DONE HERE AT
SHIPPING JOBS OVERSEAS, HURTING
WORKING FAMILIES, KEEPING WAGES
FLAT FOR DECADES, THAT'S THEIR
LEGACY AND IT'S TIME THAT THEY
OWNED IT.
>> Tucker: SO WHAT YOU ARE
SAYING IS, THEY USE CRIES OF
BIGOTRY AS A DIVERSION TO KEEP
YOU OCCUPIED ON THE DEFENSE THAT
YOU WON'T NOTICE HOW BADLY THEY
HAVE DISMANTLED THE COUNTRY.
>> IT IS STRANGE THAT WHEN YOU
POINT OUT OUT THAT BARACK OBAMA
MAKES THE SAME POINT THAT IN
INTERNATIONAL ELITE, THAT'S HIS
WORD, BECAUSE MUCH POLITICIAN IN
THEIR OUTLOOK, WHO ARE
INCREASINGLY DISCONNECTED, THE
EAGLES ON THAT SAME SPEECH TO
SAY THERE IS NO WAY TO
DISCONNECTED FROM NATIONAL
FEELING AND INCREASINGLY
DISCONNECTED FROM THE WORKERS
WHO ACTUALLY MAKE THE PRODUCTS
THAT THEY DEPEND ON WHO ACTUALLY
BUILT THIS COUNTRY.
THAT'S PRECISELY WHAT I SAID.
BUT THE LEFT CAN'T TAKE THAT.
THEY CAN'T BE PUT ON THE SPOT
AND THEY DON'T WANT TO BE CALLED
OUT AS ELITISTS THAT THEY TRULY
ARE AND THEY DON'T WANT TO BE
PUT ON THE SPOT FOR THEIR FAILED
POLICIES THAT HAVE HURT THIS
COUNTRY, THAT OF HER AT THE
WORKERS OF THIS COUNTRY, AND
THEY DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO
OFFER AND SO ALL WE GET IS WELL,
YOU ARE A BIGOT, YOU ARE A
RACIST, AS THEY TRY TO DISTRACT
FROM THEIR FAILURES.
>> Tucker: WHAT IS SUDDENLY
INTERESTING AS THE LEFT IS IN
THE DEFENSIVE THEIR PREROGATIVE
PREROGATIVES.
YOU ARE SAYING THOSE PEOPLE
DESERVE NO ATTENTION AND STOP
CRITICIZING GEORGE SOROS TO
BECAUSE I GUESS HE CAN'T BE
CRITICIZED.
IS THAT WE ARE, YOU THINK?
>> IT TOTALLY IS A LEAP WITH THE
LIBERALS ARE THE PARTIES OF THE
ELITES.
THEY ARE THE RULING CLASS.
THEY HAVE BEEN FOR DECADES.
THEY CONTROLLED THE DEMANDING
HEIGHTS IN THIS COUNTRY, THE
MEDIA, THE BIG MULTINATIONAL
CORPORATIONS, OUR UNIVERSITIES,
I MEAN, THEY'VE EFFECTIVELY RUN
THE COUNTRIES, THE LIBERALS
HAVE, FOR DECADES NOW AND
THEIR CONSENSUS HAS GIVEN US WHA
THEIR CONSENSUS HAS GIVEN US WHT
THEIR CONSENSUS HAS GIVEN US WHW
THEIR CONSENSUS HAS GIVEN US WHE
HAVE TODAY.
TO ME, THEY ARE THE ONES WHO ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR JOBS OFF
SHORING, THEY ARE THE ONES
RESPONSIBLE FOR WAGES FLAT, FOR
THE PLATE AND STRUGGLE OF
WORKING AMERICANS.
YOU KNOW, WORKING AMERICANS,
ORDINARY AMERICANS AND THE PLACE
OF WHERE I GREW UP IN RURAL
MISSOURI, THEY JUST WANT
SOMEBODY TO SPEAK FOR THEM AND
TO BE CONSTANTLY TOLD THAT THEY
ARE BIGOTS AND THEY ARE RACISTS
AND THEIR ALLIES DON'T MATTER,
THEIR VIEWS ARE MET, THEY ARE
TIRED OF THAT.
>> Tucker: WELL, YOU CLEARLY
ARE.
VERY QUICKLY, DID IT EVER OCCUR
TO YOU TO PUT YOUR HEAD DOWN --
COMING, THEY BASICALLY HATE YOU
RIGHT IN THE FACE RHETORICALLY
THE SUCKING YOU GAVE A SPEECH.
YOU DON'T SEEM INTIMIDATED.
DO YOU EVER PAUSE AND SAY OH,
IT'S NOT WORKING?
>> NO, BECAUSE I KNEW AS SOON AS
THEY WERE MAD THAT WE HIT THE
TRACK.
I KNEW THAT WHAT WE SAID WAS
RIGHT AND I'M MORE DETERMINED
THAN EVER TO SPEAK UP FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE A VOICE,
WHO HAVE BEEN IGNORED BY THE
ELITE FOR TOO LONG AND WHO, BY
THE WAY, ARE THE BACKBONE OF